starting off this hour is gonna be Joe
in Texas hey Joe how are you
howdy Dave thanks for taking the call
sure what's up
so my girlfriend and I have been
together about four years and we've
talked about getting married
we don't meant I haven't proposed or
anything like that but I'd like to do
right by her and not make her wait too
long to get married too late started in
I just started into the baby steps and
I'm in baby step - how would you
recommend saving or would you recommend
saving for the wedding at this point
well I think we I think we talk about an
engagement and we set a date and then we
back into that what do you make a year
$55,000
okay what's she make a year about 20 how
old are you - I'm 27 and she's 24
parents gonna participate in the help
with the wedding I would say probably
but I just in the mindset of planning
for them not to help out okay all right
that's fair good all right well then I
think you guys need to say what are we
gonna spend on a wedding given this
situation so it would sound like this
order of events I would get engaged I
would set a date and then I would start
talking about a budget on a wedding or
say we're gonna set the date based on
the budget for the wedding one of the
two but I mean you don't need an
expensive wedding in this situation it
doesn't make sense and and you're gonna
have to kind of talk that through with
her that's part of this process right
and then you figure out if mom and dad
are going to participate or not I
appreciate your dignity and just trying
to set this up in case mom and dad don't
participate that's a smart that's a wise
move on your part and then if the so if
they if they do help it's just gravy on
the biscuit right I mean we just get to
do a little better wedding and so if
they don't help then you've got a plan
so I how much debt do you have about 71
thousand dollars and how much debt does
she have she doesn't okay so what would
you think a wedding
to be in this situation if you were
gonna get married like six months maybe
$10,000 I like you that's exactly what I
was thinking I think it's a seven to a
$10,000 budget okay and but you've got
to get everybody on board and that's her
and you know right now this is a
discussion that's happening between you
and me and really in your mind so you've
got a you know but you could put two if
you stop your baby step two temporarily
and you just pile up cash you could come
up with the ten grand by then okay and
just then once you've got the ten grand
then restart you're getting out of debt
process and because you're not doing
something here that's uh you know that's
irresponsible I mean you're not calling
me up going I need to spend thirty five
thousand dollars or this woman on the
wedding this woman is not gonna be happy
I'm $70,000 in debt I make fifty five
that would just be stupid right and so
you know you're not doing that I would
have called you out but you're being you
know your numbers are about right and so
it's a it's a $10,000 delay in your get
out of debt plan so you have an eighty
one thousand dollar goal instead of a
seventy-one thousand dollar goal okay
that's the way I would look at it and
you're just gonna put the tent at the
front of the thing
knock it out get married now we've got a
seventy five thousand dollar income with
which once we're married with which we
can attack this debt and that's going to
accelerate then and you'll you know
you'll make up any loss ground you've
got there but and then the last piece of
advice is once you are engaged and you
have your date set and you have your
wedding budget determined we're going to
spend ten thousand dollars then you need
to back into the actual expenses of the
wedding and make them fit inside the ten
thousand dollars it's not going to
magically happen because nothing grows
faster than a wedding budget yeah yeah
I'm telling man it'll be you know father
the bride the cheaper chicken is it's a
deal it's really there so you know
you're gonna have to you know you need
to know what are you gonna spend on the
dress what are we going to spend on the
reception what are we going to spend on
the venue what are we going to spend on
the photography because you could spend
$10,000
on photography you spend $10,000 on a
dress you definitely can spend $10,000
on a reception which is usually your big
to line item by the way in a wedding
budget for those of you that are
uninitiated we've done 3 of them in the
past decade so you know but you just run
it like a project you write like
anything else but and if you don't have
some boundaries and some agreement on it
then everyone has there's a lot of
people who emotionally influence the
spending of your money that it's not
their money everyone from the
photographer that's emotionally
influenced the person selling the dress
is emotionally influencing everyone is
emotionally screwing with you the whole
time and if you don't have a line item
for it that you say this is what we're
going to spin and you and your future
spouse are in agreement and you actually
have that money in cash then you're
gonna you're gonna get to the end of
this thing and you're gonna have spent
20 grand because it'll get away from you
or 30 grand
it'll get away from you and that's what
happens and it's just because everything
seems to be a big deal there's nothing
in this budget that's not a big deal
it's all it's all a freaking drama all
the way through so hey man I like what
you're doing but you got a plan execute
the plan you're doing good